The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
Well, Donald Trump threatened to do it.
It was sort of confusing why he was
threatening to do it, but he did it.
Donald Trump has vetoed the second coronavirus
relief package that got through the House and
Senate. And now there are immediately a number
of important things here. And let me get to
what for many people is the most pressing and
important question. Does this mean that if you
were expecting a six hundred dollar check, if you
make up to seventy five thousand dollars a year,
that you will not be getting your six hundred
dollars? And the answer is, we can't say that yet,
because this may be the first time that during
Donald Trump's presidency, the House and Senate
are going to override Donald Trump's veto.
Remember that if a president vetoes a bill
passed by the House and Senate, the House and
Senate can override that with a two thirds vote
in the House and a two thirds vote in
the Senate. And that may well happen.
Reports are that the House will vote on
Monday and if the House votes to override,
the Senate will reconvene on Tuesday to
vote as well. Now, the explanation for why
Trump vetoed this bill is actually sort
of incoherent. Donald Trump with his veto
notice, saying, quote, My administration has
taken strong actions to help keep our nation
safe and support our service members. I will not
approve this bill, which would put the interests
of the Washington, D.C. establishment over those
of the American people. Now, what Trump seems
to be referring to here is what he mentioned on
Tuesday and that very strange speech he gave where
he listed countries and other environmental
and other causes that were receiving money.
But they were actually receiving the money
from the spending bill, not the covid bill,
but they were passed together. Reminder
of that from Donald Trump's Tuesday video.
This bill contains eighty five point five
dollars million for assistance to Cambodia.
One hundred and thirty four million dollars to
Burma, one point three billion dollars for Egypt
and the Egyptian military, which will go out
and buy almost exclusively Russian military
equipment. Twenty five million dollars for
democracy and gender programs in Pakistan.
Five hundred and five million dollars to Belize,
Costa Rica, El Salvador, Guatemala, Honduras,
Nicaragua and Panama. Forty million dollars
for the Kennedy Center in Washington, D.C.,
which is not even open for business.
One billion dollars for the Smithsonian
and an additional one hundred and fifty four
dollars million for the National Gallery of Art.
Likewise, these facilities are essentially
not open. Seven million dollars for reef fish
management. Twenty five billion dollars to combat
Asian carp, 2.5 million dollars to count the
number of amberjack fish in the Gulf of Mexico,
a provision to promote the breeding of fish in
federal hatcheries. Three million dollars in
poultry production technology. Two million
dollars to research the impact of downed trees.
Five hundred and sixty six dollars million for
construction projects at the FBI.
So there are about three to four ways in
which this is incoherent. First of all, the money
Trump is talking about is in the spending bill to
keep government open, which was passed alongside
the covid bill as an omnibus bill. So it is true
that these things were voted on together.
It is not true that the covid bill includes
the things that Donald Trump is mentioning, but
then adding as a next layer to this incoherence
of the spending bill, which Trump is referencing,
contains basically the same or less money
than what Trump asked for in his own budget just
some months ago. Trump asked for the money in
the spending bill that he now vetoed, which is
not actually part of the covid bill. They were
simply put together for a vote, which I'm against
doing. To be clear, Trump also said six hundred
dollars isn't enough and he wants 2000 dollars.
During that Tuesday speech, Congress found plenty
of money for foreign countries, lobbyists
and special interests while sending the bare
minimum to the American people who need it.
It wasn't their fault. It was China's fault,
not their fault. I am asking Congress to amend
this bill and increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand dollars
or four thousand dollars for a couple.
I'm also asking Congress to immediately get
rid of the wasteful and unnecessary items
from this legislation.
So once again, I agree with Trump,
but many Democrats have been talking about two
thousand dollars since May, and it's been Trump's
Republican Party that's been against more money.
Now Trump says he wants more. Well, it would have
been nice for him to push for that and lobby for
that in May when some Democrats wanted it. But
Republicans, by and large, don't don't want more
money. It's just up and down, erratic one way,
one way or the other. And
then, of course, deep down,
there may be other reasons not being mentioned for
Donald Trump's veto. One is that the spending bill
doesn't eliminate Section two thirty. Trump
has been obsessed with this. Section 230
says that if people post things that are
legally problematic to Twitter, the people
are responsible or liable not Twitter. If people
do the same thing with YouTube or Facebook,
it's the users, not the platform responsible.
Trump believes that if you get rid of Section 230
and make the platforms legally responsible, lots
of anti Trump stuff would be taken down. Trump's
just wrong about that. He just misunderstands.
And then Trump also is essentially defunding
the troops in vetoing this bill while he claims to
be the biggest supporter who has funded them more
than anybody else ever has. And then lastly,
it also appears Trump didn't like some of the
anti money laundering provisions that are in the
spending bill, not the covid bill. And we recently
learned that Jared Kushner has been running a
shell company to siphon campaign donations off
and pay salaries to Trump's own family members
and friends. So there is incoherence. There's
likely a self-serving aspect. There's really
a little bit of everything here. In the end,
the mediocre bill will probably pass
as the House and Senate is expected
to override Trump's veto next week.
Again, if all goes as it is expected to go